good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this intelligence squared
debate Dickens versus Tolstoy the Battle
of the great 19th century novelists and
I have to say is quite an honor to be on
this stage of the two distinguished
academics and experts and its wonderful
company so I'm very grateful to be here
the way we're going to do it is like
this in one corner we have Charles
Dickens great expectations of course
Bleak House you know you know the drill
and in the other we have Leo Tolstoy war
and peace Anna Karenina you know that
drill and if in fact if you could even
try and imagine 19th century literature
world literature without these Titans
try you can't now you have been polled
as you into the hall and you'll have the
chance to vote again at the end of the
evening when you heard the arguments and
seen the performances by this great
great company so you should have all
have a voting slip with Dickens and
Tolstoy printed on it tear the slip into
and put one or other name into the
ballot box when the time happens and if
you're still undecided put the whole
thing in a box okay all right everybody
chills ready here we go for Charles
Dickens stage right John Mullen Lord
Northcliffe professor oh sorry Lord
Northcliffe professor of modern English
literature University College London
John is written among many many things
an acclaimed book on Jane Austen and
next year he will be publishing Dickens
tricks a book about the techniques
Dickens uses in his fiction and staged
left for Leo Tolstoy
we have Simon Schama Simon is University
professor of art history and history at
Columbia University in New York
he's one of Britain's most
popular and admired historians and
television broadcasters and he invented
a genre as far as I'm concerned his
latest book is belonging the second
volume of his history of the Jewish
people and can we have a hand for John
signer
now - I don't like the word illustrate
because actors don't illustrate they
will be the characters in this work and
they will bring it to life for you and
first of all can we have a hand for the
company in general
Zoli Ashton is stage right she starred
in the television shows wanderlust and
fresh meat her screen credits include
Greta misfits
Sherlock and Gorilla Zoe Ashton
next to her is the very distinguished
actor and I'm trembling to even say the
words Timothy West who is playing magnet
as we say in Chicago Grace in this stage
he has played Macbeth
King Lear Uncle Vanya on stage and his
film credits include the day of the
jackal the 39 steps and Oliver Twist mr.
Timothy West
next to mr. Weston's Julia Sawalha who
gave me a beautiful lesson on her name
and I will never forget that she is
known for her iconic performance in
BBC's absolutely fabulous and also
because that year he is also the star of
Cranford and Lark Rise To Candleford as
well as numerous stage and film roles
Julia Sawalha
[Music]
nexi julia is mr. Tom Hiddleston star of
stage and screen and whose leading roles
include the BBC's the hollow crown and
the night manager for which he recently
won a Golden Globe
and last but definitely not least kick
Kingsley on our far right
[Applause]
get this this is the deep thing you
never say things like a star is born on
stage that's bad look all I'm gonna say
is this is a great one and this ladies
and gentlemen is his professional debut
now we are going to stay strictly to
time and I'm gonna be that's why they
asked me I think to be the timekeeper
I'm going to ask each of our advocates
and it start with Simon one minute your
passion how did you find Tolstoy well I
had had a really good friend who died
much new young who was a friend of mine
at college and he simply could not
believe that anyone had the temerity to
call themselves an historian without
actually having read war and peace so I
did immediately while I was actually
having a job in the I was the only only
straight man in the soft furnishings
department at Liberty's yeah yeah so I
used to go around the corner to a veggie
restaurant and get my dose of Tolstoy as
Tolstoy would have wanted and never look
very good thank you
and John well I think it's all down to
some nickel mister reggiani I fear isn't
with us anymore but if he is out there I
owe it all to you mr. reggiani
who was a rather sardonic occasionally
slightly sneery
English teacher who did a wonderful
thing which was once a week I think it
was on Friday and I think it went it was
when he was tired and bored he would
read aloud to us every Friday and that's
what he did in English and I remember
that two books he read aloud were
Alistair MacLaine's force 10 from
Navarone
which actually was quite good and and
David Copperfield I realize now he must
have a much abridged it but it was just
hearing him read it out and we're gonna
have a bit of David Copperfield later
but I was still here mr. Richie on his
voice as a kind of desk and I think so
it's so for both of you these were
pivotal moments a moment that this work
spoke to you at some point and became
you became yeah I think I mean I would
say to to scramble things up a bit my
father used to read Dickens every Sunday
after tea yeah actually my dad finally
saved not enough money to have his first
summer holiday and on the way to
Victoria Station actually ran into a
bear a boy with complete set of Dickens
and he exchanged his holiday money for
that set of Dickens which I now have so
I'm you know this is an evening of
demise to embarrass us conflict for me
and divided divided love we start now
with John Mullen and Dickens
thank you okay so I'm going to play an
honorable poet here and I I determined
before I arrived here that I wasn't
going to be oppositional no way you want
me Stan that's good that's good
I feel that mr. krummel's as an illusion
I thought I'm not going to be
oppositional and compare and contrast
and slag off or anything like that but I
will after all I thought I I loved
Tolstoy
are quite like Simon but I thought I
would just say one little thing about
Tolstoy and Dickens right at the
beginning and that is just anecdotal
really which is a couple of years ago I
visited Tolstoy's country house he has
nya Pollyanna about 150 miles south of
Moscow and we were getting it was a
British Council Beano and so we were
getting the sort of the full tour and
from a Tolstoy expert and I was shown
into the room where Tolstoy died where
also his last place of study and writing
was and he shifted his study around the
house at different times and she said
she told us the one thing remained
constant wherever he was working and
writing in his years in the house was
the picture above his desk and you know
what I'm gonna say don't you the picture
above his desk was a portrait still
there the very one and it's a portrait
of Charles Dickens
we could stop there could we maybe it's
a portrait of Charles Dickens and he had
it there every time he looked up
thinking what's Kitty gonna say next
there was Charles Dickens and that's
because I think Dickens did what I would
argue he does to many many writers but
actually to all his readers and weirdly
even to some people who sort of haven't
actually read a whole novel but have
heard the words phrases even bits of
dialogue on TV or cinema he feeds our
imaginations like no other writer I
meant to say as a claim for his special
prowess the most important thing about
Dickens and the way he feeds our
imaginations is he's funny
he's funny but that's not right it's not
quite right I think it's better to say I
decided that I changed from the Victoria
Line to the Jubilee Line and thought
saying he's fun he's not good enough
that's not right he's funny when he
shouldn't be that's what's great about
Dickens
he's funny at the wrong times in the
unexpected places where everybody's at a
funeral on her deathbed he's funny and
he himself had a description of what he
was doing when he was funny and the
wrong places at the wrong times and it's
in Oliver Twist and he says he's
comparing his writing very
characteristic of Dickens he's comparing
his writing to the stage melodrama much
despised by critics much loved by
audiences of his day and he's talking
about the way in a staged melodrama of
his day just after a scene where
somebody's languishing and then dungeon
somebody will come on and sing a comic
song and he says that his writing like
such melodrama is he says like a side of
streaky bacon the tragic in the comic
you see absurdly alternate but as he
says that's what it's like isn't it
that's what my
it's like the absurd and the comic
alternating alongside each other when
they shouldn't be and I hope you'll hear
that in our first reading which has got
quite a bit of freaky bacon s in it I
think it doesn't need much introduction
because it's the opening of a novel it's
the opening the very opening of great
expectations
[Applause]
country down by the river within as the
river wound 20 miles of the sea my first
most vivid and broad impression of the
identity of things seems to me to have
been gained on a memorable raw afternoon
towards evening at such a time I found
out for certain that this bleak place
overgrown with nettles was the
churchyard and that Philip spirit late
of this parish and also Georgiana wife
of the above were dead and buried and
the Alexander Bartholomew Abraham Tobias
and Roger infant children of the
aforesaid were also dead and buried and
that the dark flat wilderness beyond the
churchyard intersected with dikes and
mounds and gates with scattered cattle
feeding on it was the marshes and that
the low leaden line beyond was the river
and that the distant savage lair from
which the wind was rushing was the sea
and that the small bundle of shivers
growing afraid of it all and beginning
to cry was PIP Algernon's cried a
terrible voice as a man started up from
among the graves at the side of the
church porch or I'll cut your throat a
fearful man all in coarse gray with a
great iron on his leg a man with no hat
and with broken shoes and with an old
rag tied round his head a man who'd been
soaked in water and smothered in mud and
lamed by stones and cut by flints and
stung by nettles and torn by briars who
limped and shivered and glared and
growled and whose teeth chattered in his
head as he seized me by the chin Oh
don't cut my fruit soup right don't do
it sir tell us your name
what pip sir once more give it mouth pip
pip sir show us where you live yep put
out the place I pointed to where our
village today
on the flat ensure among the older trees
and Pollard's a mile or more from the
church the man looking after me at the
moment turned me upside down and emptied
my pockets
there was nothing in them but a piece of
bread when the church came to itself for
he was so sudden and strong that he made
it go head over heels before me and i
saw the steeple under my feet when the
church came to itself i say i was seated
on a high tombstone trembling while he
ate the bread ravenously you young dog
will fetch eeks you got I believe they
were fat though I was at the time under
sized for my years and not strong der me
if I couldn't eat him and if I didn't
know I thought the mind Joey I earnestly
express my hope that he wouldn't and
held tighter to the tombstone on which
he had put me partly to keep myself upon
it partly to stop myself from crying
that lookee here where's your mother
if he started made a short run and
stopped and looked over his shoulder
faster also Georgiana that's my mother
so and is that your father along I meant
your mother yes him too late of his
parish who do you live with supposing
your Connolly led to him which I had
made up my mind about my sister sir mrs.
Joe Gargery wife of Joe Gargery the
blacksmith sir let's meet said he and
looked down at his leg after darkly
looking at his leg and me several times
he came closer to my tombstone took me
by both arms and tilted me back as far
as he could hold me so that his eyes
look most powerfully down into mine and
mine looked most helplessly up
international career big question mean
whether you're to be allowed to live do
you know what a fine yes and you know
what wigglers is yes after each question
he tilted me over a little more so as to
give me a greater sense of helplessness
and danger you dipped me a file and you
get me Wiggles he tilted me again you
bring them both to me he tilted me again
alright of your liver he tilted me again
I was dreadfully frightened and so giddy
that I clung to him with both hands and
said if you were kindly pleased to let
me keep upright sir perhaps I shouldn't
be sick and perhaps like an attendant he
gave me a most tremendous dip and roll
so that the church jumped over its own
weathercocks
then he held me by the arms in an
upright position on the top of the stone
and went on in these fearful terms you
bring me tomorrow morning early that
file and then Whipple's you bring a lot
to me and that now battery over there
you do it and you don't never dare say a
word or dare to make a sign concerning
your having seen such a person as me or
any person some ever and you should be
left to live you fail or you get left on
my you my my my words in me and
beginning then they tell any person
whatever no matter how small it is then
your heart and your liver shall be tore
out roasted and ate
so I'm trusting not just to Dickens but
to keep my secret weapon for but to are
entangled of course because as I
remember from mr. reggiani reading David
Copperfield what Dickens does his
childhood like nobody else but I hope
you could hear the streakiness of the
bacon they're that incredible opening
scene from great expectations is a real
place isn't it on the Kent marshes you
can go there actually you can see the
graves but it's also a weird place from
a fairy story it's a frightening episode
and it's also a comical episode
it's those combinations which are so
extraordinary so true to the fantastic
part of all our lives also you hear I
think in that in that reading especially
in Tim's wonderful impersonation of
Magwitch what dickens contributed to all
our imaginations and our ears his idea
Lex as the academics pompously call it
the voices of all his characters each
one different each one distinctive of
themselves in the next passage however
because we're gonna have quite a lot of
dialogue I wanted a little snatch of
something different but in a way just as
important which is an example I sort of
snatched out of why the adjective
Dickensian has become so easy a part of
our language Dickensian as a word for
all sorts of things one of them being an
embracing adjectives for the kind of
force of his imagination that takes a
place in this case it's going to be
London and both describes it and
transforms it so now as a little example
of that Tom is going to read from a
section of the opening of
big house fog everywhere fog up the
river where it flows among green eights
and meadows fog down the river where it
rolls defiled among the tiers of
shipping and the water side pollutions
of a great and dirty city fog on the
ethics marshes fog on the Kentish
heights fog creeping into the cabooses
of collier bricks fog lying out on the
yards and hovering in the rigging of
great ships fog drooping on the gunnels
of barges and small boats fog in the
eyes and throats of ancient greenwich
pensioners wheezing by the fire sides of
their wards fog in the stem and bowl of
the pipe of the wrathful skipper down in
his closed cabin fog cruelly pinching
the toes and fingers of his shivering
little apprentice boy on deck chance
people on the bridges peeping over the
parapets into a nether sky of fog with
fog all around them as if they were up
in a balloon or hanging in the misty
clouds gas looming through the fog in
diverse places in the streets much as
the Sun may from the spongy fields be
seen to loom by husbandmen and plowboy
most of the shops lighted two hours
before their time as the gas seems to
know for it has a Haggard and unwilling
look
yeah I mean the more Dickens less of me
the better chance I have I Weber don't
Lee I mean you can hear perhaps you know
it goes on for pages is all as wonderful
as that and you can hear perhaps what is
if you're a little critic so wonderful
about Diggs he breaks every rule for how
you're supposed to write he repeats
himself he personifies gloriously and
illogically he loves the fantastic those
people seeming to float in a balloon in
the fog and a little earlier in there in
the opening from the passage that Tom
read he allows him he's that he's
describing how awful it is in November
in LA and London and he says it's
there's as much mud he says in the
streets as if water's had but newly
retired from the face of the earth and
it would not be wonderful to meet a
Megalosaurus forty feet long or so
waddling like an elephantine lizard up
Hoban hill it's the first dinosaur in
English fiction trivial fact
and it's wonderful it's monstrous
appalling and utterly comical with its
central London waddle Dickens is fiction
is full of delicious grotesquerie and
monsters but his monsters are such that
you let but he lets the reader see how
they'd been formed and this next passage
that Zoe and Julia are going to read is
an example of that it's from great
expectations pip who's aged 23 now moons
hopelessly after Estella the
hard-hearted Estella who's been reared
by Miss Havisham to be hard-hearted and
one day Estella and pip are summoned
from London by Miss Havisham to visit
them and they go back to satis house and
pip overhears the following dialogue
between Estella and Miss Havisham
[Applause]
at least I was no party to the compact
for if I could walk and speak when it
was made it was as much as I could do
but what would you have you have been
very good to me and I owe everything to
you what would you have loved you have
it I have not mother by adoption
retorted Estella never departing from
the easy grace of her attitude never
raising her voice as the other did never
yielding either to anger or to
bitterness mother by adoption I have
said that I owe everything to you all I
possess is freely yours all that you
have given me is that your command to
have again beyond that I have nothing
and if you ask me to give you what you
never gave me my gratitude and Duty
cannot do impossibilities did I never
give her love cried Miss Havisham
turning wildly to me did I never give
her a burning love inseparable from
jealousy at all times and from sharp
pain while she speaks to leave us don't
call me mad let her call me mad why
should I call you mad I of all people
does anyone live who knows what set
purposes you have half as well as I do
does anyone live who knows what a steady
memory you have half as well as I do I
who have sat on this same hearth on the
little stool that has even now beside
you there learning your lessons and
looking up into your face when your face
was strange and frightening me time soon
forgot that no not forgotten not
forgotten
no but treasured up in my memory when
have you found me false to your teaching
when have you found me unmindful of your
lessons when have you found me giving
admission
here she touched up wasn't with her hand
to anything that you excluded be just to
miss havisham pushing her away wishing
her gray hair with her who taught me to
be proud you praised me when I learnt my
lesson Miss Havisham with her former
action who told me to be hard who
praised me when I learnt my lesson
having some quite shrieked as she
stretched out her arms miss teller
looked at every moment and with a kind
of calm wonder but was not otherwise
disturbed when the moment was passed she
looked down at the fire again I cannot
think said Estella raising her eyes
after a silence why you should be so
unreasonable when I come to see you
after a separation I have never
forgotten your wrongs and their causes I
have never been unfaithful to you or
your schooling
I have never shown any weakness that I
can charge myself with would it be
weakness did you return my love but yes
yes she will call it so I begin to think
that Estella an amusing way after
another moment of calm wonder did I
almost understand how this comes about
if you had brought up your adopted
daughter wholly in the dark confinement
of these rooms and had never let her
know that there was such a thing as the
daylight by which she had never once
seen your face if you had done that and
then for a purpose had wanted her to
understand the daylight and know all
about it you would have been
disappointed and angry Miss Havisham
with her head in her hands
set making a low moaning in swaying
herself on her chair but gave no arms Oh
which is nearer and nearer Kay
if you had taught her from the dawn of
her intelligence with your utmost energy
and might that there was such a thing as
daylight but that it was made to be her
enemy and destroyer and she must always
turn against it for it it had blighted
you and would else blight her if you had
done this and then for a purpose had
wanted her to take naturally to the
daylight and she could not you would
have been disappointed and angry Miss
Havisham said listening for a moment but
it seemed for couldn't I see her face
but still made no answer so I must be
taken as I have been made the success is
not mine the failure is not mine but the
two together make me
I mean Miss Havisham's a monster you I
feel sorry for her don't you
that's his trick or one of his many
tricks to show you how people are made
and twisted and pip all the time is
listening to this and he too has been
made by his expectations into a
different kind of monster he's wonderful
at populating our imaginations with
these characters populating on a
language with these characters I mean
just think that there are more
characters in Dickens who become words
in the Oxford English Dictionary than
those of any other novelist Gradgrind
bumble Heep pick sniffy um they've come
adjectives pub slapper II nouns Micawber
ish best of all maybe Scrooge I mean
it's impossible to kind of face the fact
that he invented that it seems snatched
out of nature itself in the last reading
I want to come back to that strange
mixture of the dark and the comical the
grim and the funny that is so
distinctive of Dickens and is the thing
he shares I think with Shakespeare the
jesting in the graveyard Samuel Johnson
said about Shakespeare the mourner in
Shakespeare's the mourner tramps to the
funeral
the reveler staggers from the inn and
that's how it is in Dickens where
funerals are almost inevitably
inadvertently funny in this last passage
which is from David Copperfield
we are che Micawber David and you've got
to the most important thing to remember
for this passage is David Copperfield is
twelve years old in this passage his
mother has died and the ghastly
murdstone's have sent him to work in the
blacking factory his one solace is that
he has lodgings with the Micawber's but
then they mr. Micawber is arrested as he
inevitably always is for debt and sent
to the debtors prison
this passage he's just been released so
there's a little bit of celebration and
the company David mr. micawber mrs.
micawber numerous children and the or
fling the or fling by the way is an
orphan from the workhouse who works who
is so down on her luck that she's the
Micawber servant and this is what
happens I passed my evenings with mr.
and mrs. Micawber during the remaining
term of our residents under the same
roof and I think we became fonder of one
another as time went on on the last
Sunday they invited me to dinner and we
had a loin of pork and apple sauce and a
pudding I had bought a spotted wooden
horse overnight as a parting gift to
little Wilkins Micawber that was the boy
and a doll for little Emma I had also
bestowed a shilling on the offing who
was about to be disbanded we had a very
pleasant day though we were all in a
tender state about our approaching
separation I shall never master Koth
Copperfield revert to the period where
mr. Micawber was in difficulties without
thinking of you your conduct has always
been of the most delicate and a
relighting description you have never
been a larger you have been a friend
again
couple feels though he had been
accustomed and accustomed to call me of
late has a heart to feel for the
distresses of his fellow-creatures when
they are behind a cloud and ahead to
plan and a hand to ensure the general
ability to dispose of such available
property as he could be buried away with
I expressed my sense of this
commendation and said I was very sorry
we were going to lose one another my
dear young friend I am older than you a
man of some experience in life and of
some experience in short in difficulties
generally speaking at present and until
something turns up which I am I may say
hotly expected I have nothing to bestow
but advice still my advice is so far
worth taking that in short I have never
taken it myself and mr. Micawber who had
been beaming and smiling all over his
head and face up to the present moment
checked himself and frowned the
miserable crutch that you'll be home I
saved returned mr. Micawber quite
forgetting himself and smiling again
the miserable wretch you behold my
advice is never do tomorrow what you can
do today procrastination is the thief of
time
kawaii my call papaw's maxim my dear
your Bob aunt was very well in his way
and heaven forbid that I should
disparage him tell him for all in all we
near sell in sort make the acquaintance
probably of anybody else
possessing at his time of life the same
legs for gaiters and able to read the
same description of print without
spectacles but he applied that maxim to
our marriage my dear and that was so far
prematurely entered into in consequence
that I never recovered the expects mr.
Micawber looked aside at mrs. Micawber
and added not that I am sorry for it
quite the contrary my love after which
he was grave for a minute or so my other
piece of advice
Garfield you know annual income 20
pounds annual expenditure 19 and six
result happiness annual income 20 pounds
annual expenditure 20 pounds ought and
six result misery the blossom is
blighted the leaf is withered the god of
day goes down upon the dreary scene and
and in short you are forever floored as
I am to make his example the more
impressive mr. Micawber drank a glass of
punch with an air of great enjoyment and
satisfaction and whistled the college
horn pipe I did not fail to assure him
that I would store these precepts in my
mind though indeed I had no need to do
so for at the time they affected me
visibly
our time is sadly almost up but perhaps
you could hear in that wonderful passage
that mixture of melancholy and buoyancy
that enjoyment and relish when you're
supposed to be serious or grim that is
so distinctive of Dickens disaster and
hilarity together and actually I think
for Dickens as for mr. Micawber what's
so wonderful about him but language his
language is his consolation as it was
Dickens is okay I've got a really good
final language I save for later all
right
[Applause]
that was John Mullen and the company for
Charles Dickens
Simon Schama from Leo Tolstoy
how many of you read Tolstoy put up your
hands not bad but not a majority I tell
you why I'm asking you dear friends and
that's because I think I know that
Tolstoy in some sense would have hated
the idea of who's winning and who's not
for Tolstoy really in a war for example
nobody wins in life somehow
everybody wins and Johnny's is right
that Tolstoy didn't really like Dickens
he worshiped Dickens he actually heard
Dickens in 1861 when he was in London he
heard Dickens reads a Christmas carol in
one of his performances and James's Hall
in in Piccadilly and we don't know
really quite what he had thought of
Christmas Carol but them the thought
struck me that actually Tolstoy's joke
book is quite thin and he can bet your
life there's not much in Tolstoy that
would have made it to a panto I think it
the way a Christmas Carol tears I think
there was something what I want to try
and do rather than win actually don't
give a toss who wins because I love them
both what I do care about and what I
feel that count Leo would care about
would try and persuade all those of you
who never gone near Tolstoy so big so
forbidding so daunting that he actually
being inside Tolstoy's books is not so
much reading as actually having a life
with it the best thing that was ever
said about Tolstoy I think was by the
Russian writer isarc barber who said if
the world could write itself it would
write like Tolstoy now why is that
Tolstoy who actually made one go out
writing like Dickens in particular David
Copperfield
wrote it as his book called a childhood
and
ken's was translated very very quickly
into russia and it's one of the most
small Kishin awkward and forced and
sentimental and disingenuous of all the
things that Tolstoy did so what Tolstoy
did was go to a different place and the
different place that he went to was into
the modern world he's as much part of
our experience more sir perhaps than he
was of the 19th century and what he did
not want to do eventually was be
theatrical like Dickens he doesn't
actually have characters in his book he
has people he couldn't imagine having
the veneerings and a pink sniffs and the
McRoberts and the magwitch's they are
ordinary names of ordinary people
Dickens of course wrote to perform he
wrote for you he wrote for an audience
Tolstoy
only read out loud once in his life to a
small group of family and friends in
1864 was very shy we know he'd entered
all a lot of different parts but what he
wanted to do really was throw open a
window you could simply climb through
that window and be in that world so that
sometimes the writing compared to
Dickens his great extravagant look at me
applaud me theatricality is flat and
limpid and sometimes even chilly and
there's another reason for that too
Tolstoy went to places Dickens didn't go
namely to the war he went to yon Europe
he went on a raid to a village with his
brother Nikolai to Chechnya he served in
the Crimean War
he saw the full horror of war and I
think for Toaster at that moment
actually any kind of flamboyance
disgusted him at the end of it very end
of his writing life he came back to the
experience he spoke many many languages
including some caucasian languages like
Turkmen he came back to Haddix
an astonishing story some of the
greatest things that Tolstoy ever did
are short stories and this one it's
called [ __ ] Murat it's a long short
story he came to it and went back from
it many times between 1896 and 1904 this
is chapter from chapter 70 in the
shortest in [ __ ] Murat and it's an
account of what happens to a village in
the Caucasus a Chechen village when the
Russian army Rhea it has got through it
two words which otherwise will sound
very weird and out all is a Chechen
village and the salia is a house and
[ __ ] Murat is a Chechen chieftain who
had been part of the resistance of the
Russians when over now decided he'd go
over to the Russians because he hated
the local Imam and the story begins with
[ __ ] Murat being received in this
particular village but after the
Russians had got through with it this is
what happens
the owl devastated by the raid was the
one in which had Amuro to spent the
night before his coming over to the
Russians Sardo with whom [ __ ] Murat had
stayed was leaving for the mountains
with his family when the Russian has
approached the owl when he came back to
his own he found his sack Lea destroyed
the roof had fallen in the doors and
posts of a little gallery were burned
down and the inside was before 'old his
son the handsome boy with shining eyes
who looked rapturously at [ __ ] Murat was
brought dead to the mosque on a horse
covered by a Booker he'd been stabbed in
the back with a bayonet the fine looking
woman who'd waited on [ __ ] Murat during
his visit now in a smock torn in front
reading her old sagging breasts with her
hair on down stood over her son and
clawed her face until it bled and wailed
without ceasing Sardo took a pick and
shovel and went with some relation is to
dig a grave for his son the old
grandfather sat by the wall at the
destroyed sacked layer and whittling a
little stick stared dully before him
he'd just come back from his apiary the
two haystacks formerly there had been
burned the apricot and cherry trees he
had planted and nursed were broken and
scorched and worst of war the beehives
had all been burned the wailing of women
could be heard in all the houses and on
the square where two more bodies had
been brought the small children wailed
along with their mothers hungry cattle
who had nothing to eat also bellowed the
older children did not play but look to
their elders with frightened eyes the
spring had been be fouled
obviously on purpose so that it was
impossible to take water from it the
mosque was also be fouled and the mother
and his assistants were cleaning it up
the old heads of households gathered on
the square and squatting down discussed
their situation of hatred for the
Russians
no one even spoke the feeling that was
experienced by all the Chechens big and
small was stronger than hatred it was
not hatred
but a refusal to recognize these Russian
dogs as human beings and such loathing
disgust and bewilderment before the
absurd cruelty of these beings that the
wish to exterminate them like the wish
to exterminate rats venomous spiders and
wolves was as natural as a sense of
self-preservation
like Dickens Tolstoy was very interested
in geography in specifics of place and
indeed in nature nature is a real actor
I think I would one of the things like
John I don't at all want to be
opposition on this but one of the things
I think not Tolstoy does because he
lives so much in the country he lives
with the seasons so very much on on his
estate that he's wonderful about animals
and actually possibly you could make an
argument I won't make it here that the
very greatest thing he ever wrote was a
short story called master or a man
the cast of which are two peasants one
is a peasant merchant and a horse AB a
gelding and the haughty who head off
into a snowstorm and it would be a
spoiler to tell you with what
consequences that is but nature is not
capture nature is ferocious nature is
extraordinary especially the Russian
winter of course and there is a great
fog passage 8 there in war and peace we
we're now going to have a fog off
actually you know that option families
of fog offs you know they wouldn't let
anyone look at them it was completely
stumbling around but the fog for Tolstoy
is a fog which actually hangs over the
battlefield at Austerlitz
and it's not the thing that John very
cunningly and wisely I to love
absolutely that opening of the accounts
my dad performed it magnificently my dad
should have met mr. Rohani I think but
he goes on and on and folks and frogs
and frogs and the fog eventually is a
kind of piece of dramatic filmic play it
settles around the hedge of the Lord
Chief Justice
but tell story has a real fog and it's
the fog that is concealing it's the the
in the morning of the fog before the
battle the folder lifts from the height
of the hill but the fog just stays in a
foggy bottom and with tremendous
tremendous kind of consequences and it's
it's it's another kind of real fog the
fog was so thick that though day was
breaking one couldn't see 10p
ahead bushes look like ignore must reads
level places like cliffs and slopes
everywhere on all sides want might run
into an enemy invisible few paces away
in the bottom where the action began the
fog was still thick but al-bab Ovid had
cleared but nothing of what was
happening could be seen from above down
below danger for the Russian army nine
o'clock in the morning and unbroken sea
of fog spread below but at the village
of schlopp on its on the heights where
Napoleon stood surrounded by marshals it
was perfectly light over him was the
clear blue sky and the enormous ball of
a Sun like a huge hollow crimson float
bobbed on the surface of the milky sea
of fog fantastic surf and very often
actually the great force of you being
there is built up from these sharply
perfectly described physical moments
often the greatness of Tolstoy's work is
built up from these little tiles of tiny
details as well
he is same time cosmic and imperious an
Olympian and panoramic and might minut
things my favorite little tile at sort
of tessera really is when the Battle of
Borodino incredibly bloody battle had
happened and among its casualties are
Prince Andrei and Anatole two
antagonists and a field surgeon emerges
from the tent of a field hospital
Tolstoy describes him holding a cigar
and I can't do it my old arthritic
chronic hands between the thumb and the
little finger why because the middle
fingers are covered in blood and he
doesn't want to light a cigar while
blood is all over it reality a hard
vivid brutal thing the other thing to
introduce the next reading is that well
I think actually Tolstoy has a grip upon
a particular reality of the lives of
women we heard this as
wonderful exchange between Miss Havisham
and Estella but so many of Tulsa's are
so many of Dickens's women are either
monsters or angels two monsters one has
brought up the other monster in Great
Expectations toss story it seemed to me
actually and they both treated women
badly Oh though Tolstoy loved his wife
Sofia throughout his life or however
strong me it was tossed Roy knew how
women relate to each other and one
passage I wanted we want now to give you
is actually two sisters this is the so
called subplot but it's terribly
important from Anna Karenina their share
bats key sisters kitty the young one
dolly the old one they both suffered the
whole famous opening of Anna Karenina is
dolly share bat Sookie has been betrayed
by her adulterous husband so she it
somehow wants to keep the marriage
together but she's distraught and warm
down by what she has to go through Kitty
the young one has turned down the man
who really loves her mangled leather
into his Tolstoy in disguise because
she's actually in love with Vronsky the
clothes source for whom Anna Karenina
falls they come together as sisters that
they come together in a kind of tortured
passion
[Applause]
entering Kitty's small boudoir a pretty
little pink room with dolls as young
pink and gay as Kitty had been just two
months earlier
dolly remembered with what gaiety and
love they had decorated this little room
together last year her heart went cold
when she saw Kitty sitting on the low
chair nearest the door staring fixedly
at a corner of the rug Kitty glanced at
her sister and her cold somewhat severe
expression did not change I'll leave now
and stay put at home and you won't be
allowed to visit me I would like to talk
to you about what what else if not your
grief I have no grief calm down kitty
can you really think I don't know I know
everything and believe me it's nothing
we've walked on through it kitty was
silent and her face had a stern
expression he's not worth your suffering
over him yes because he scorned me kitty
said in a quavering voice don't talk
about it don't why who told you that no
one said that I am sure he was in love
with you and is still in love but dark
these condolences are the most terrible
thing of all for me kitty cried out
suddenly getting angry she turned on her
chair flushed and quickly moved her
fingers clutching the belt buckle she
was holding now with one hand now with
the other dolly knew this way her sister
had of grasping something with her hands
when she was in a temper she knew that
Kitty was capable of forgetting herself
in such a moment we're saying a lot of
unnecessary and unpleasant things and
Dolly wanted to calm her down but it was
already too late
what what if it you want to make me feel
what Kitty was talking quickly though I
was in love with a man who cared nothing
for me and then I thought I'm dying of
love for him and I'm told this by my
sister who thinks that but that she's
commiseration I don't want these pitying
xand pretenses Kitty you are unsightly
on the contrary III I see that you are
upset but in her temper Kitty did not
hear I have nothing to be distressed or
comforted about I'm proud enough never
to allow myself to love a man who does
not love me but I'm not saying it one
thing tell me the truth
tell me did Levin speak to you the
mention of Levin seemed to take away the
loss of Kitty's self possession she
jumped up from the chair flinging the
buckle to the floor and with quick
gestures of her hand began to speak why
bring Levin into it too I don't
understand why do you need to torment me
I said and I repeat that I am proud and
would never never do what you're doing
go back to a man who's betrayed you
who's fallen in love with another woman
I don't understand I don't understand
that Yuri but I can't and having said
these words she glanced at her sister
and seeing that dolly kept silent her
head bowed sadly Kitty instead of
leaving the room as she had intended sat
down by the door and covering her face
with a handkerchief bowed her head the
silence lasted for some two minutes
dolly was thinking about herself
her humiliation which she always felt
echoed especially painfully in her when
her sister reminded her of it she had
not expected such cruelty from her
sister and was angry with her but
suddenly she heard the rustling of a
dress along with the sound of suppressed
sobs bursting out and someone's arms
encircled her neck from below kitty was
kneeling before her so one happy she
whispered guiltily
for love is beloved's go often of the
sunset in Dickens Agnes and David Dora
says you know call me your wife child
Tolstoy is the first of the great
righteous I think it looks forward to
Stromberg and Epson who actually
understands love can make you obsessed I
can turn bad it can turn it can be very
unhappy flow there does that he's very
very close to that I think and Anna
Karenina one of the most extraordinary
things in a passage we're going to read
now is actually the point at which the
two lovers Anna and Vronsky who should
be in the throes of infatuated joy a
cloud actually passes between them why
because Anna has just told run skill
tells Vronsky that she has told her
husband what's going on and this is an
extraordinary passage about how men and
women lovers both respond in completely
different ways Vronsky the magnificent
military horse riding clothes horse only
can think of himself fighting a duel
that's what he thinks of immediately
that is not what's on Anna's mind let's
read this
[Applause]
you're not angry there's I sent for you
it was necessary for me to see you
serious and stern set of her lips he
could see behind the veil immediately
changed his state of mind I angry but
how did you come why here never mind
come we must talk he understood
something had happened that this meeting
was not going to be joyful in our
presence he had no will of his own not
knowing the reason for anxiety but he
already felt that this same anxiety
involuntarily communicated itself to him
what is it what she walked a few steps
in silence gathering her courage and
suddenly stopped I didn't tell you
yesterday but on the way home with
Alexei Alexandrovich I told him
everything I said that I could not be
his wife but I told him everything he
listened to her involuntary leaning his
whole body towards her as if wishing in
this way to suffer the difficulty of her
situation but as soon as she'd said it
she suddenly straightened up in his face
acquired a proud and stern expression
yes yes it's better a thousand times
better I understand how difficult it was
but she wasn't listening to his word she
was reading his thoughts in the
expression this face she couldn't have
known that his expression reflected the
first thought that occurred to him that
a duel was now inevitable the thought of
a duel had never entered her head and
therefore she explained this moment or
expression of stern --less differently
having received her husband's letter she
already knew in the depths of her soul
everything would remain as before that
she would be unable to score on her
position to leave her son unite herself
for their lover the morning spent at
princess first grace had confirmed her
still more in that but all the same this
meeting
was extremely important to her she hoped
it would change their situation and
saver if at this news he should say to
her resolutely passionately without a
moment's hesitation abandon everything
and fly away with me she would leave her
son and go with him but the news did not
produce in him what she expected the
only inseam insulted by something was
the least bit difficult it got done by
itself I understand I understand he
interrupted taking the letter without
reading it and trying to calm her I
wished for one thing I asked for one
thing to break up this situation in
order to devote my life to your
happiness are you telling me that I
possibly doubt it if I did is that
coming
France Key says suddenly pointing at two
ladies coming towards them maybe there
nois he hastened to turn down a sidewalk
drawing her after him as I said that is
not the point
I cannot doubt that but there is what he
writes if here is what he writes to me
read it again is in the first moment of
the news of her break with her husband
Veronica while reading the letter
involuntarily yielded to the natural
impression aroused in him by his
attitude towards the insulted husband
now as he held the letter in his hands
he involuntarily pictured to himself the
challenge she'd probably find today or
tomorrow the duel itself during which
he'd Samba the same cold and proud
expression now in his face having fired
into the air awaiting the insulted
husband shot and at once there flashed
into his head what he himself had
thought that morning that it was better
not to bind himself and he knew he
couldn't tell her this thought having
read the letter he raised his eyes to
her and there was no firmness in his
look she understood that once he already
thought it over to himself she knew that
whatever he might tell her he would not
say everything he thought and she
understood her last hope
had been disappointed this was not what
she'd expect
one of the most
[Music]
you know straight on to the next thing
because another great thing the
extraordinary felt that um he sort of
had mixed feelings didn't like
theatricality so much because the great
drama in all Tolstoy's writing the
greatest drama are interior monologues
he invents stream of consciousness
writing I'm sure James Joyce actually
took a lot often the right that the
speech is broken and though these gaps
were is actually said is often betrayed
by body language rather than actually
the words themselves and one of the
greatest passages a stream of
consciousness so fierce in and it's
taken directly from Tolstoy his life is
when levin ii hero really the hero of
the male hero of the book and this again
is out of time it speaks to us all how
many parents in here you're all paris oh
except for kitsch who is going to be one
as well as a star this is what happens
when levin is waiting for the birth of
his child his wife kitty
he did not know whether it was late or
early the candles are all burning low
Dali had just come to the study to
suggest that the doctor lie down
Levin sat there listening to the doctor
tell about a quack mesmerist and
watching the ashes of his cigarette it
was a period of rest and he become
oblivious he's entirely forgotten what
was going on now he listened to the
doctor story and understood it suddenly
there was a scream unlike anything he
had ever heard the scream was so
terrible that Levin didn't even jump up
but holding his breath gave the doctor a
frightened questioning look the doctor
cocked his head to one side listening
and smiled approvingly
it was also extraordinary that nothing
any longer astonished Levin probably it
should be so he thought and went on
fitting whose scream was it he jumped up
ran tiptoe to the bedroom went round
Lizaveta Petrovna in the princess and
stood in his place at the head of the
bed the screaming had ceased but
something was changed now what he did
not see her understand nor did he want
to see and understand but he saw it from
Lizaveta Petrovna space her face was
Stern and pale and still just as
resolute her jaws twitched a little in
their eyes were fixed on kitty
Kitty's burning tormented face with a
strand of hair stuck to her sweaty
forehead was turned to him and sought
his eyes her raised hands after his
seizing his hands in her sweaty hands
she started pressing them to her face
she spoke quickly he could and tried to
smile but suddenly her face became
distorted then she pushed him away from
her go she cried and again came that
scream
Levin flashed his head and ran out of
the room he knew that all was now lost
leaning his head against the doorpost he
stood in the next room and heard a
shrieking and howling such as he had
never heard before and he knew that
these cries were coming from what once
had been kitty
he had long ceased wishing for the child
he now hated this child he did not even
wish for her to live now he only wished
for an end to this terrible suffering
doctor what is it what is it my god
she said season is not to buy the arm as
he came in Amma doctors face was so
serious as he said it that Levin
understood this nearly over to mean she
was dying forgetting himself he ran into
the bedroom the first thing he saw was
there's a better Petrovna space it was
still more Stern and frowning Kitty's
face was not there in place of it where
it used to be was something dreadful
both in its strange looking in the sound
that came from it he leant his head
against the wooden bedstead feeling his
heart was bursting the terrible
screaming would not stop it became still
more terrible and then as of reaching
the final limit of the terrible it
suddenly stopped Levin did not believe
his ears but there could be no doubt the
screaming stopped and there was a quiet
stirring a rustle and quick breathing
and her faltering alive gentle and happy
voice softly said it's over he raised
his head her arms resting strength ously
on the blanket remarkably beautiful and
quiet she silently looked at him and
tried but was unable to smile
[Music]
[Music]
it
you ain't heard nothing yet it nearly is
over but the last the last section we're
going to give you is actually my
favorite in all of Tull stories right
here it comes from great climatic
moments in war and peace and toast oh
really is that's a lot of people of
notice two writers he's the writer of
the of power of the public world of the
absurdity of history but he's also the
writer of view as you've been listening
to of the intensity and complicated
truth of the passions between men and
women between brothers and brothers and
friends and sisters and children and
parents and all these things come
together at a particular moment the
moment is this
Natacha the extraordinary exuberant girl
at the heart of war and peace who's
based actually on toasters and wife's
younger sister tatyana tanya has been
engaged be married the cold brilliant
Prince Andrei who like an idiot and said
women have to wait for a year to see if
it really is going to be good and during
the year which is unbearable for someone
of Natasha's warm blood
she almost elopes she does she falls in
love with someone who's already married
as we discovered Anatole Caraga and a
beautiful no-goodnik technical Russian
term and and she's discovered and she's
disgraced and what happens to this life
force of war and peace is that she
becomes ill she hates everybody she
hates her family she who had loved them
all she hates herself she's close to
dying of all this terrible feeling and
then eventually somehow the spectral
spectral race of a girl comes back to
life and looking on all the time is pure
bezel cough another version of Tolstoy
Pierre who wanted Andre and Natasha to
be married but who finds himself caught
between them he wants to be a friend to
Russia but something inside his heart
and his body and his head also wants to
be some
thing more most of all he wants to
somehow he can't he knows he can't bring
their Tasha and Pierre back together but
most of all watch no you can't of course
not you told Tolstoy know this you know
let's just do it let's just do this it
Natasha wasted with a pale and stern
face not at all shamefaced as Pierre
expected her to be was standing in the
middle of the drawing-room when Pierre
appeared at the doorway she became
flustered
obviously undecided whether to go to him
or wait for him Pierre hastily went up
to her he thought that she would give
him her hand as always but coming close
to him she stopped breathing heavily in
lowering her arms lifelessly in exactly
the same pose in which he came out to
the middle of the room to sing but with
quite a different expression Piazza
curvature Prince Bolkonsky was your
friend is your friend she corrected
herself it seemed to her that everything
only was and that now it was all
different he told me then to turn to you
Pierre sniffed silently looking up at
her up to then he had reproached her in
his soul and had tried to despise her
but now he felt such pity for her that
there was no room in his soul for
approach he's here now
tell him to forgive me she stopped him
began to breathe still more rapidly but
did not cry yes yes I'll tell him but he
did not know what to say
Natasha was Evan Lee afraid of the
thought that might have occurred to
Pierre no I know it's all over no it it
can never be I'm only tormented by the
wrong I've done him tell him only that I
beg him to forgive me forgive me for
everything her whole body shook and she
sat down on a chair
a feeling of pity such as he had never
experienced before overflowed Pierre's
soul I'll tell him I'll tell him
everything wants more but I'd like to
know one thing what I'd like to know
whether you loved Pierre did not know
what to call Anatole and he blushed at
the thought of him whether you loved
that that bad man
don't going bad but I don't know I don't
know anything she began to cry again a
still greater feeling of pity tenderness
and love took hold of Pierre he felt
tears flowing behind his spectacles and
hoped they would not be noticed let's
not talk anymore my friend it seems so
strange suddenly the Natasha to hear
that meek tender heartfelt voice let's
not talk my friend I'll tell him
everything but one thing I ask you
consider me your friend and if you need
help advice or simply to pour out your
soul to somebody not now but when your
soul is clear remember me I'll be happy
to if I'm able she was about to leave
the room appear held her back by the
hand he knew he had something more to
tell her that when he said it he was
surprised at his words himself stop it
stop it you have your whole life ahead
of you
as me know for me all is lost all is
lost
if i were not i but the handsomest
brightest and best man in the world and
i was free
i would go on my knees this minute and
ask for your hand and your love Natacha
for the first time in many days wept
tears of gratitude and tenderness and
after glancing at pierre left the room
pierre to following her almost ran out
to the front hall holding back the tears
of tenderness and happiness that choked
him put on his coat and missing the
sleeves got into the sleigh where to now
sir ask the coachman where to Pierre
asked himself where can I go now not to
the club or to pay visits all people
seem so pitiful so poor in comparison
with a feeling of tenderness and love he
experienced in comparison with that
softened grateful glance she'd given him
at the last moment through her tears her
said Pierre throwing open the best skin
coat on his broad joyfully breathing
chest
despite the ten degrees of frost it was
cold and clear above the city semi dark
streets above the black roof stood the
stark starry sky only looking at the sky
did Pierre not feel the insulting
baseness of everything earthly compared
with the height his soul had risen to at
the entrance to our bat square the huge
expanse of the dark starry night opened
out to peers eyes almost in the middle
of that sky over precious dense key
boulevards to the huge bright comet of
the Year 1812 surrounded strewn with
stars and all skies but different from
them in its closeness to the earth it's
white light and long raised tail the
same comet which presaged as they said
all sorts of horrors and the end of the
world but for Pierre this bright star
with its long luminous tail did not
arouse any frightening feeling on the
contrary
Pierre his eyes wet with tears gaze
joyfully at this bright star which
having flown with inexpressible speed
through immeasurable space on its
parabolic course suddenly like an arrow
piercing the earth seemed to have struck
here it's one chosen spot in the black
sky and stopped its tail raised
energetically it's white light shining
and playing among the countless other
shimmering stars it seemed to Pierre
that this star answered fully to what
was in his softened and encouraged soul
now blossoming into new life
garbage on
and company over there with Simon genre
and company for leo tolstoy I'd like to
ask the company a question this is I
guess a playwrights question to you
anybody can answer how do you as actors
prepare to come into pros as opposed to
text to play text because there are
different machines so as as as actors
and type of building working do you
enter it differently or is it the same
anybody I think even if you're on your
own you have to say it out loud that's
what I experience with this because
reading both Dickens and Tolstoy in your
head was very different how it came out
on the stand the feeling of it moving
through you when you said it out loud so
saying it out loud as much as possible
to get a proper handle on then the
difference as it moves through you as
opposed to it working in your head was
really interesting I really actually
enjoyed that particularly when you're
playing a character it's awesome
question because I think round about how
Tolstoy wrote Dickens wrote in serial
form had to check toast why not I think
no story I mean it was very shortly Anna
Karenina he wrote he started in 1873 and
it took him I think was seven years to
write war and peace 5,000 pages of
drafts
ODEs to his wife who so he was very very
slow and painstaking and Anna Karenina
that he thought in 1873 he's got it
nailed and he didn't took him another
four years the first draft of Anna
Karenina actually the the husband
the anak run on top is a kind of hero
and the more he thought about it and
allure is the kind of scarlet woman and
he's just waiting for her to come to a
sticky end that absolutely changed in
the relentless redrafting so that she's
fully Ambu so he was sort of thee I
think he would have loved to have
actually turned it all out like for you
as actors research this is your research
this is what you do as you're going into
a role and I'm interested in the
difference out for you building
physically voice because you're building
as you're working with character and a
play text is much different you come on
stage and you have a script that's a
different thing you have huge over your
lights you have all these things and you
guys that work you all have picked up a
text and entered it so just wondering if
there's anything you can share with the
audience especially young actors young
theatre people going into it for the
first time how do you enter how do you
enter this I mean I interesting thing
about both Tolstoy and Dickens it is the
richness of description you you know
with the play you just have the the
dialogue and so I'm trying to think of
you think of Pinter or Beckett or your
look at you're basically looking for
subtext because underneath the meaning
of the things people say are the things
people mean sometimes they don't say
what they mean
whereas with Tolstoy in Dickens you've
got these long passages of where the
both writers invite the reader into the
mind of the protagonist or the character
so that Tolstoy peace with Levin waiting
for Kitty to give birth it's actually in
the third person but it's written with
such a momentum that it feels it like
it's in the first person in some way
yeah and so actually that's true of all
if you're if you're ever in a situation
as an actor where you're there's there's
a book it's a it's such a blessing
because you can go to the book and look
at all this interior tea
to shore up the exterior which is what
we have to present as actors so that's
that's okay go okay cuz cuz Simon I
don't know if you noticed rather like
the author of war and peace can I ask
you something as you when you're doing
this yes I'd like you to tell us because
all of these these novels are immortal
they live now they don't live in the
past they live now in Dickens what women
and as part of your your answer what
women for you live now
now who speaks to us now well I think I
think that the I chose I suppose that
exchange between Estella and Miss
Havisham because in it's weird and
twisted way it seems to me as vivid as
it's would have seemed to its first
readers and you know she mishaps and
says said call me mad and this teller
says no you're not mad and it's true
that and I knew Simon we mention it that
Dickens does terrifying women and
angelic women and that she's not
top-notch on his sexual politics of his
fiction but I think in general actually
I miss my appeal to the audience there's
much less embarrassing or excessive or
in poor taste in Tolstoy Tolstoy was a
count you heard
Simon describing his writing method come
on and on and on and on Dickens wrote
compendium extravagantly within this
sort of tiny bits incredible discipline
of the of the the periodical form and I
think that he gave us characters if you
like out a fantasy including women like
a stellar and Miss Havisham but I
suppose what I'm saying is fantasies
truer than reality in a way or find the
fantastic is
be truer than the realistic if you want
the realistic you want
Tolstoy you want George Eliot's but it's
because Dickens has a handle on the
fantastic including in his depiction of
characters like a stellar and Miss
Havisham that that his words live on in
our thoughts and in our sayings and I
sort of think in our dreams really we
just say he in a sense invented a kind
of our secular life in in some ways I
think that I think he gave us like all
great great novelists and I think
comparisons are odorous you know I mean
I think more than Tolstoy in this sense
he gave us characters that I mean I have
a weird domestic life and I'm sorry Mike
my wife and I say things like a bit of a
uriah he hmm pushing that way I mean he
gave us a kind of psychological
vocabulary and that's not the same he
didn't give us anybody as
psychologically complex as Dorothea
Brook in middle marched he gave us sort
of strange strange distorted examples of
the way we all are sometimes and that's
that's a different kind of thing and
that seems to be something that actually
kind of survives more vividly thank you
very much
open I'm going to open it
you promise me okay I'm gonna give you
that's on him you got it but you got
limited times give me money give me a
minute and then do it well I think
actually I even though I I
Joan is absolutely right that Dickens is
I mean it's more than ever it seems
ludicrous that we should have this
gladiatorial slam but you know that's
what we have absolutely right Dickens
gave us the kind of extravagant
possibilities the Father frontier of the
human imagination and we need that and
nobody did it other than Shakespeare
exactly like him
Tolstoy when I said Tolstoy I love
Dickens and transcended it what Tolstoy
wanted to do in the greatest things he
wrote and he carried on writing great
things all in great fat novels was to
make us look the reality of life sound
so bleep so pedantic in a way but
Tolstoy actually could because he had
such sharp eyes and he could actually
translate poetically what she saw into
this exquisite language that everything
we do going to sleep at night
playing with children being terrified in
war has a kind of startling startling
enhance crispness and freshness things
that we think we do suddenly seem as
though we'd never done them before very
interestingly he became of course an
impossibly sententious moral teacher
there's one wonderful moment where he
said I'll actually I'm very happy to
entertain any problems that students
might have so two students came a long
way from the Urals to see Tolstoy and
they say the servant answer the door yes
niya Paulina and they say we've led
Nikolai which you know has said we can
ask him any questions and the master
said I'm not refusing and he goes to our
story and says Tosca is young men of
thousands of miles from New York so she
said I'm not in and then immediately he
said that he bronzed the door and said
young man I've sinned I've sinned what's
your question and they said well leveler
can i that you promised you say is that
is wrong to resist evil with violence
but what if a tiger sprang at you from
the jungle and Toaster he looks through
them and said young man such things very
seldom happen you know so he gonna be
impossible nope nothing like I promise
tough very lasting a moral teacher
called Baba Rican gave him his two
novels to read and Tolstoy said they're
incredibly bad and I'll tell you why
they're bad and this is what he says and
it sums up the Tolstoy case the aim of
an artist is not to solve a problem
irrefutable but to make people love life
in all its manifestations if I were told
that I could write a novel whereby I
might irrefutable established the
correct point of view on all social
problems I would not even devote two
hours on such a novel but if I were told
the what I should write would be read in
about twenty years time by those who are
now children that they would laugh and
cry over it and love life I would devote
all my own life and all my energies to
it
that was gorgeous that was gorgeous but
you know who are involved bill they
would give you the hook at this point
right but that was gorgeous all right
here are the final tallies before these
distinguished gentleman spoke to us and
their advocates we were 44% for Dickens
40% for Tolstoy and 16% for decays the
undecided now after debate
we are 42 percent for Dickens 53% for
Tolstoy
[Applause]
[Music]
before we go I have to say my preference
because everybody well the actors didn't
look actors should do this as well but
yes after the company first go I mean
you got to pick one sorry your company
which one who would you who okay
[Applause]
mr. West yeah ticking jump right
Dickens because my dad and then we're
gonna get off the stage if there is
another life that we were all given to
live one of the things I like to live
and do in it is read Russian so I made
toast alright so thank you all
[Applause]
let's have a round of applause for this
magnificent company who come out to the
foie gras
for our to advocate Simon Schama one and
John Mulligan
Wow
round of applause for intelligence
squared who presented this and a round
of applause to yourself because I want
to say I don't know if the company felt
this but I just felt the intelligence
the attention and the whole energy just
coming this way you made it so much
easier for all those we were nervous so
thank you